whether you're a devoted stranger thanks
fan looking for a refresher or a casual
fan looking for a point of reference
we're digging into the history of
Hawkins Indiana's association with the
upside-down from the first experiments
conducted at Hawkins lab to the Battle
of Star courts and beyond the chain of
events that kick things off actually
began more than a decade before the
series itself in 1969 dr. Martin Brenner
arrives at Balkans National Laboratory
to oversee the MKULTRA program which
dowsed test subjects with hallucinogenic
drugs in an effort to manifest
superhuman abilities she was a part of
some study in this College MKULTRA yeah
that's the one
it's through this new screening process
that he eventually meets Terry Ives who
took part in the MKULTRA trials at
Hawkins in the early 1970s though she
apparently didn't know it at the time
Terry was pregnant when the trials began
when he discovers this dr. Brenner
hatches a plan to take control of
Terry's eventual baby at all costs after
undergoing MKULTRA trials that included
some time in a sensory deprivation tank
Terry Ives gives birth to a daughter she
would have named her baby girl Jane but
Brenner immediately orchestrates a
cover-up claiming that Terry had
actually miscarried before she was
eventually discharged from the trials
terry is convinced that she had a baby
and files lawsuits in an attempt to get
information but her efforts failed
around 1974 Terry attempts to infiltrate
Hawkins lab and steal the baby back but
she's apprehended in an effort to keep
her baby secret Brenner subjects her to
intense electroconvulsive therapy before
releasing her back to her sister in a
vegetative state for the rest of her
life
Terry can only repeat the sequence of
events leading up to her capture on an
endless loop breathe simpler
Ranko 450 breathe with the cover up
seemingly secure Brenner continues to
groom Terry's daughter whom he dubs 11
by forming a father-daughter bond with
her and urging her to call him Papa at
some points in the 1970s eight manages
to escape and flee to Chicago where she
forms a chosen family of misfits and
sets out to exact vengeance on anyone
tied to the MKULTRA program as the 70s
turned into the 80s Brenner continues
frequent testing of Elevens abilities
which ultimately include both
telekinesis and telepathy he starts
small asking her to use her mind to
crush a coca-cola can but then attempts
to push her further by asking her to use
the same ability on a living cat when
she refuses he attempts to confine her
to a locked cell and while resisting 11
kills two guards with her mind
inadvertently granting Brenner a
successful test of her telekinesis on
living tissue next comes more advanced
tests of her telepathy which began by
asking 11 to listen to the thoughts of a
man elsewhere in the lab she's able to
not only hear him but to broadcast what
he's saying over the labs loudspeakers
Brenner then pushes further putting 11
in a sensory deprivation tank to test
the limits of her eavesdropping ability
when she's pushed even further she makes
contact with a strange monster
apparently from another world
Brenner intrigued by this wants to dig
deeper on November 6 1983 xi is tasked
with making contact with a monster again
the mission goes wrong and xi
accidentally opens a gate between
dimensions allowing the creature to
break loose and kill scientists within
Hawkins lab before escaping in the chaos
xi also manages to flee the lab
triggering a wide search for her during
which government agents are constantly
covering their tracks on Brenner's
orders the monster later dubbed the
demagogue and flees into the woods
around Parkins and ultimately abducts a
young boy will Byers who's on his way
home after a game of Dungeons and
Dragons with his friends Mike wheeler
Dustin Henderson and Lucas Sinclair it
was a seven
the wool it was a seven a demo Goran
it got me the Hawkins community begins
an intensive search for will but it is
ultimately his mother Joyce who
discovers that he's in another dimension
during the search another local barb
Holland is abducted by the demagogue and
during a party will and Barb revolt
taken to the demagogue ins home to
mention a dark place that the Hawkins
kids will later dubbed the upside down
meanwhile the hunt for eleven continues
as government agents ruthlessly search
for her killing witnesses to tie up
loose ends
including the kindly owner of a local
diner who gave her food the killing in
the diner combined with will buyers his
disappearance leads police chief Jim
hopper to begin investigating these
strange things in earnest 11 still on
the run meets up with Mike Dustin and
Lucas and ultimately convinces them that
she can help find wil Brenner and his
government cronies engineer a dramatic
cover-up faking wills death by planting
a dummy body in a local reservoir
everyone believes it's really will
except for Joyce and 11:11 succeeds in
convincing Mike by using her powers to
protect his voice from the upside down
bull hopper follows Joyce's suspicions
to the morgue and discovers the body is
full of cotton he decides to infiltrate
the Hawkins lab to find out what's
really going on and briefly glimpses the
gate before he's knocked unconscious and
returned to his home under government
surveillance hopper researches the lab
and finds evidence of Terry Ives and the
MKULTRA trials he enjoys traveled to
meet Terry and are told by her sister
Becky that Terry always believed she had
a secret daughter meanwhile Barb's
friend Nancy who is also Mike's sister
and Will's brother Jonathan have come to
believe that a monster is responsible
for Barb's disappearance and Nancy
briefly enters the upside down while
searching for it in an effort to amplify
her eavesdropping powers the boys build
a sensory deprivation tank for 11 at
Hawkins middle school she discovers barb
died but will is alive being pursued by
the demagogy Innes at Hopps dimensions
Joyce and hopper returned to Hawkins lab
to confront Brenner who reveals that he
and his men are unable to control the
demagogue head meanwhile Nancy and
Jonathon returned to the buyers house
and set traps for the demagogue gun
where Joyce is repeatedly seen both it's
and will
the walls with the help of Nancy's
boyfriend Steve they fight it but it
flees in the upside down Joyce and
hopper locate will now pinned down and
intertwined with a large alien tendril
bay Priam and hopper perform CPR until
he's breathing again they return to
Hawkins at the school Brenner and his
agents converge on 11 when the
demagoguing suddenly appears 11
confronts it directly and uses her
powers to apparently disintegrate it but
in the process she herself vanishes a
month after the demo Gorgon is defeated
there are still echoes of what came
before Brenner was attacked by the
demagogue on and then seemed to
disappear from Hawkins as the lab came
under new management Mike misses 11 and
begins regular attempts to make contact
with her on his radio hopper who
received some mysterious information
from someone in a car at the end of the
first season begins leaving food out in
the woods for 11 - fine hoping to lure
her back we later learned that 11
efforts sent her into the upside down at
some points in November of 1983 she
broke free hiding in the woods before
being secretly taken in by hopper months
later in June of 1984 Russian scientists
attempt to use a machine called the key
to access the upside down they fail and
new plans are made to try to access the
Dark Dimension from another location be
a covert land purchases in Hawkins
Indiana in October of 1984 there's more
trouble brewing 11 is beginning to grow
restless using her powers to explore the
possibility of contacting Mike again out
in Hawkins proper hopper is bothered by
a seemingly simple new problem
complaints of crop deterioration around
the area including the local pumpkin
patch meanwhile Nancy and Jonathon
learned that Barb's parents have
convinced a private investigator to look
into their daughter's disappearance
the biggest problem however is brewing
within will buyers ever since he came
back from the upside down he's been
experiencing strange symptoms connected
to it including visions of a massive
spider-like creature towering over the
horizon
finally on Halloween night will has
another vision and tells Mike that he's
been seeing things after a night spent
trick-or-treating Dustin comes across a
strange lizard-like creature from the
upside down in the trash can behind his
house
Dustin names the creature d'Artagnan or
dart for short and while it's initially
small enough to fit into a terrarium it
soon grows dramatically until it's the
size of a dog soon the gang comes to
discover that there are more of them and
that they've invaded the town through
new entrances to the upside down in
tunnels caused by the continued spread
of that dimensions influence as well
buyers opens up to his mother about his
visions which ultimately turn into
seizures he begins scribbling out
drawings to explain his psychic and
physical links to a new creature that
the kids called a mind flayer these
drawings form a map that corresponds to
the dead props hoppers been seen pinky
no River and there it is does he notice
it when he investigates these things
directly he falls into the tunnels
revealing just how far the contamination
has spread meanwhile 11 has begun
digging through hoppers old evidence
files for information about her mother
she reconnects with Terry through a
psychic link uncovering Terry's failed
attempt to save her baby
[Music]
having recognized her mother 11
hitchhikes to the Ives halt convincing
Becky to let her see Terry as she probes
her mother's mind 11 has shown a vision
of a little girl she used to play with
in the lab and with the help of old
photos Becky provides her she heads for
Chicago there 11:00 meets Kali who's
been in hiding after her time in the lab
for years using her perception altering
powers to survive while nurturing a
group of misfits Kali helps 11 to
realize the full extent of her gifts and
helps her to feel as though she isn't
alone in the world
she also lets eleven in on her mission
finding and killing those who were
responsible for ripping them from their
families and experimenting on them at
first xi is eager to exact vengeance on
bad people who harmed her and her mother
but when she realizes Kali is asking her
to purposefully and mercilessly kill
people in cold blood she ultimately
declines to be part of it and after
seeing a vision of Mike and hopper in
danger and Hawkins as a result of the
escalating activity of a mine player she
decides to go home
Will's increasing physical deterioration
at the hands of the mine player coupled
with the violence of the demo dogs all
suggest some sort of hive mind as at
work this all leads to a showdown in
Hawkins lab in which numerous people
including Joyce's boyfriend Bob are
killed their struggle is helped along by
the return of eleven and a plan is
hatched to keep the mind player blind
and distracted
Joyce Jonathan and Nancy take a sedated
will to hoppers cabin and try to use
intense heat to drive the player out
meanwhile Mike Dustin Lukas Steve and
their new friend max will set fire to
the tunnels as a distraction 11 and
hopper will sneak back into the lab
where 11 will use her powers to close
the gate she inadvertently opened a year
earlier the plan ultimately works the
mine player is forced out of will 11
closes the gate and the kids all escape
the tunnels alive put the threats from
the upside down apparently at an end
due to evidence Jonathan and Nancy
gathered throughout the season Hawkins
lab is shut down after a public outcry
and barb is given a proper funeral
hopper meets with the labs new director
Sam Owens who grants him legal custody
of 11 - a forged birth certificate to
maintain their father-daughter
relationship
as the season ends in December of 1984
all the kids get together for the annual
snowball dance during which eleven and
Mike finally become a couple and Max and
Lukas also get together as they
celebrate it's revealed that the mine
player is still very much alive and is
watching them all from the upside-down
signaling that it's not done with its
attempt to conquer just yet in the early
months of 1985 Russian scientists make
some illicit land deals with Hawkins
Mayor Larry Klein after buying property
they move into a clandestine facility
beneath the star Court wall and
construct a new version of the key which
marks the beginning of a new connection
between our world and the upside down on
June 28 1984 a blackout hits Hawkins and
rats in the area began flocking to the
old Bryn Bourne steelworks on the edge
of town for unknown reasons this
escalates when Billy Hargrove max's
older stepbrother crashes his car near
the steelworks on the night of june 29th
in a daze Billy is swept into the
steelworks and possessed by the mine
flare with the gate slowly reopening the
mind flayer has found a way to
re-establish its hive mind in Hawkins
breaking down the rats bodies and using
them as raw material to build itself a
horrifying new form meanwhile on a
hilltop outside of town
Dustin sets up a radio antenna he built
fall at summer camp in an effort to
communicate with his long-distance
girlfriend Suzy he's unable to reach her
but he does pick up a strange message in
Russian which he records and takes the
Steve who now works at the local mall JQ
he here is who
Steve's co-worker the scoops of whey ice
cream shop
Robin believes she can decipher the code
with the help of a Russian dictionary
then now possessed Billy abducts his
coworker at the local pool Heather and
exposes her to the mind flayers
possession as well as part of a
sleepover prank eleven eavesdrops on
Billy's mind and suspects something is
amiss eleven and Max begin to
investigate while Jonathan and Nancy
investigate the rats meanwhile Joyce
alerts hopper to some strange magnetic
activity she's noticed around town and
asks him to take her back to the lab you
stand me up no phone call no apology
because you had to go to Scott Clark's
house they begin investigating while
Robin Steve and Dustin realized that the
Russian message as a code related to the
star Court wall itself Joyce and hopper
intimidate Klein who comes clean about
his ties to secret land purchases around
town they visit one of the property's a
farm house and discover Russians at work
in the basement confirming a Soviet
presence in town even as the scoops
group at the mall is also uncovering
similar details meanwhile will tells his
friends that he can sense the mine
players presence and they suspect that
Billy has been taken over the kids trap
Billy in a sauna at the pool confirming
the presence of the mine flare and it's
hide mine which has now infected the
residents of Hawkins as the kids try to
figure out what to do about the mine
player Dustin Robin Steve and Lucas's
little sister Erica have accidentally
infiltrated a Russian facility beneath
the mall Joyce and hopper managed to
capture Alexi a Russian scientist and
take him to Murray Ballman to get him to
translate after being bribed with a
Slurpee Alexi explains the entire plot
to use the key to open the gate to the
upside down again at Hawkins and hopper
places a call to Owens to ask the
government to intervene
you get it you want to fight back in
Hawkins the mind flayer is now aware
that the kids are onto it and begin
sending possessed people to attempt to
kill or convert them Robyn and Steve are
captured in the facility and Erica and
Dustin hide and eleven goes into the
void and discovers the mine player who
reveals its plan to convert all of
Hawkins to its cause
growing until it breaks out of the
steelworks on the night of July 4th 1985
all of the major players and Hawkins
converge on star court mall the kids
head there after elevenses Dustin in the
Boyd and Dustin Erica Steve and Robyn
all managed to escape the underground
facility the mine player pursues them
hoping to possess or destroy 11 once and
for all what Joyce and hopper head into
the facility to destroy the key and
close the gate once again a battle
ensues with the kids distracting the
mine player by throwing fireworks at it
down in the Soviet facility the other
team gets a little help from Dustin's
girlfriend Susie who provides Planck's
constant via the radio to help them gain
access after singing the theme to the
neverending story Billie appears to stop
11 but when she uses memories of his
childhood to get through to him Billie
remembers who he really is and
sacrifices himself to save her
at the same time popper battles the
Terminator like grigory near the key
then tells Joyce to shut the Machine
down the key explodes the gate closes
the mind flayer is destroyed and hopper
is apparently killed in the blast
outside Sam Owens and a squadron of
government agents arrived in October of
1985 three months after the Battle of
Star courts the buyers family now
including eleven is Joyce's adopted
daughter plan to move away from Hawkins
mayor Cline has been arrested the
Russian plot discovered and Hawkins has
become something of a conspiracy
theorists dream town the biggest change
of all dough seems to be that eleven no
longer has her powers having been
drained by her battle with the mind
flayer she and Mike make a pact to see
each other again for the holidays and
the buyers drive away after eleven reads
a speech about what hopper wanted for
her future at an unknown date some time
later at a facility in Kamchatka Russia
soldiers have shown feeding an unnamed
man to a captive demagogue and before
they do though they mentioned the
American in another cell the American is
not named but it's implied that it could
be Jim
still alive check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]